I love then the cocktail party when she
said for the first time that's what she
said she just made out with Michael in
the in the bathroom at the cocktail
party he writes her like a love note and
tells her he loves her and and she's
just sort of like I know I can't even
imagine being with Michael but with
Mitchell he's just made out with it or
it's just a ridiculous
the first kiss in the chilis parking lot
was ridiculous and surprising and I
think to everybody even to me haha let's
go what Steve's great but it was it was
the characters and the way the
characters dynamic was just so push-pull
and so kind of this rub that was like
awful but so pleasurable you know that
just sort of made you want them to hook
up it just made you want it in the
dinner party episode definitely throwing
the dundie at the mini television is
hilarious and breaking it I would like
to just say that I hit that small
television every single time and all the
guys on the crew were so impressed with
me
I also liked in that episode the very
inappropriate dancing to Hunter song do
you guys remember my old assistant
hundred like John Krasinski like going
under his alarm it's just so so
completely inappropriate and great and
off and I'm a dancer so it was
particularly fun for me to try to like
dance really badly like a little bit off
the bead and not quite in the rhythm but
like completely turned on by this
ridiculous song by this you know 20 year
old guy I guess my last one would be
when she comes back with a huge boob job
in order to get Michael back oh it's so
stupid and the breastfeeding the
breastfeeding like and singing the song
you know there's so many good ones so
many good one
you